يحدث الآن الآلاف في
جنازات الفلسطينيين الـ12 الذين قتلوا
في العملية العسكرية الإسرائيلية الأخيرة في
الضفة الغربية، انسحبت القوات الإسرائيلية
من جنين وأنهت أكبر
عملية عسكرية لها في الضفة الغربية منذ
20 عامًا أو في الصيف، ويعيش عبد العزيز على
الأرض في  جانين تحصل على وصولنا الأول
إلى هناك، ما الذي يمكنك أن تخبرنا به
جيدًا أولاً، يجب أن أشرح لك سبب
رؤيتك لي من الأعلى، ولكن
ذلك بسبب عدم وجود
بنية تحتية متبقية في هذا المخيم، ولا توجد
مياه جارية، ولا كهرباء، ولا إنترنت،
لذلك يجلس المصور الخاص بي.  شرفة
وأنا هنا أقدم لكم
منظرًا من مستوى الأرض، يمكنك بالفعل رؤية
أكوام الأنقاض التي بنيت فيها، وذلك
لأن الصخور قامت بالفعل
بتطهير هذه المنطقة، وهذا أحد
الشوارع الرئيسية هنا في المخيم وقد تم
تحويله إلى طين
تم تدمير جميع البنية التحتية هنا بسبب واحدة من
أسوأ الغارات التي شهدها هذا المخيم منذ
حوالي 20 عامًا، ومرة ​​أخرى
يأتي الناس لليوم الأول فقط لأن
هذه الغارة انتهت للتو في اليوم الأول،
وهم يعيدون بعضهم، لذا مرة أخرى
هذا النطاق الواسع  دمر بعضها
المنازل التي دمرت بالكامل.
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه كان
يستهدف البنية التحتية للإرهاب، وأنه
دمر مواقع الأسلحة وكان هدفه
تحييد ما يسميه
ملاذًا إرهابيًا هنا في جانين، لكن العديد من هذه
العائلات أخبرتنا أنهم كانوا ببساطة  لقد وقعت
في مرمى النيران، أعني أنظر إلى
الأضرار التي لحقت بهذه السيارة، وبعض هذه
السيارات مرة أخرى يمكنك رؤيتها متناثرة في جميع
أنحاء هذه العائلات، سبعة آلاف إلى
ثمانية آلاف شخص ليس لديهم الآن مكان
للنوم الليلة، لذا تتجول هذه العائلات في
محاولة لمعرفة ما هو الأمر
منزلهم لا يزال قائما أين
ينامون الليلة ماذا حدث لمنزلهم